il est après midi les 15 sélectionnés de
la squadra azurra sont venus reconnaître
le terrain du parc des princes
ils devaient être rejoints dans la
soirée par trois équipiers du talibé
paoli des systèmes et ron ayant fait
match nul avec la belgique b à charleroi
les grandes vedettes du football
transalpin corso le maître à jouer de
l'inter et son grand rival en
championnat italien arrivé admira c'est
ainsi que facchetti legrand à rire
offensif de l'inter vont certainement
posé pas mal de problèmes à l'équipe de
france
quant au gardien alberto si il a été
finalement préféré un aigri uniquement
pour les guérir en vue de la coupe du
monde de même que le dmi pirovano dont
c'est la première sélection
pendant ce temps là l'équipe de france
terminé son stage dans le cadre
enchanteur de l'hôtellerie du château de
fère en tardenois dans l'aisne henri
guérin ce match contre l'italie vous en
attendez quoi exactement
eh bien il entre dans le cadre de la
préparation de la coupe du monde bien
entendu mais je pense que le match en
lui-même
disons se suffit car à masr des italiens
c'est quelque chose de qui se situent
ils ont presque au sommet puisque
jusqu'à présent contre l'état il devient
vite vu que des échecs
marcel aubour vous êtes d'un de ses
titulaires à part entière de l'équipe de
france on compte sur vous pour la coupe
du monde et pourtant dans votre club à
l'olympique lyonnais tout ne va pas pour
le mieux vous prenez pas mal de buts ces
derniers temps on traverse un mauvais
passage à te découper rémois alors tout
le monde que la confiance mais je pense
que ça va revenir
vous aimez un match marcel aubour où le
gardien est sollicité ab oui c'est bien
plus intéressant pour une gardien être
sollicité parce que ça met en confiance
tandis que si on touche une balle tout
des dix minutes les quarts d'heure si
c'est une balle cariou fond des filets
sa voix çà n'est touché l'insee c'est
pas bon berne en beauce qui au contraire
de votre camarade marcel aubour vous
personnalisé dans cette équipe de france
l'équipe de clubs en forme du moment
sochaux qui est en quarts de finale de
la coupe de france et qui somme toute
n'a plus rien à craindre ni à espérer du
championnat
vous avez donc le moral oui le moral
toujours on a toujours le moral surtout
à 23 ans et quand on a la chance de
jouer dans une équipe de france est dans
une équipe de club qui marche pourtant
bosquet vous aller opérer dans cette
équipe de france au poste d'arrière
droit qu'il n'est plus le vôtre à
sochaux depuis pas mal de matches déjà
oui effectivement ça fait 1 environ que
je n'ai plus joué au poste d'arrière et
le match que nous avons effectué hier à
wattignies m'a permis de me replacer un
petit peu car avant l'entraînement
j'avais des doutes
j'avais peur de ne pas bien me situer
par rapport à mes camarades
maintenant ça va oui auxerre on a parlé
en ce qui vous concerne philippe bond
d'une cheville endolorie
je dois avouer que c'est la vérité
au moins sur la malléole puisque c'est
une plaie ouverte alors c'est quand même
très douloureux mais ça ne m'empêche pas
de courir et de frapper mal frappé c'est
plus difficile mais comme c'est quand
même l'intérieur du pied pour fois pour
but un concert plutôt du coup de pied